now we know the 49ers will be in arizona
for at least their next two home games
maybe beyond because of an order in
santa clara county preventing the 49ers
from playing in their stadium the
chargers in the rams now are on notice
of the possibility that los angeles
county eventually will fall within
parameters that justify
a stringent stay-at-home order that
potentially would keep the chargers and
the ramps from playing in their home
stadium it ties into the number of icu
beds and the order was passed earlier
this week here's sean mcvay the rams
coach from yesterday on the question
of whether he's heard about the
possibility that the rams won't be able
to play at sofi stadium
have not now haven't heard anything of
that nature lindsay um so
i think uh you would probably know as
soon as i do if anything was affected
but we know uh we're focused on the
cardinals and and uh don't anticipate
that to be an issue with uh next week's
game if that's what you're alluding to
as well
you know i think i'm going to need some
dramamine or something if they're going
to keep using these moving backgrounds
it started with roger goodell at
halftime in the raven steelers game
where that background was moving on this
tilted 3d thing that was mesmerizing and
now i don't know what was going on
behind sean mcvay but seriously i got a
little woozy during that
yeah no doubt mike and it's funny to see
all these different coaches at their
homes and then you see them in their
facility at different places in the
facility we've seen some some pretty
good backgrounds but it's going to be
interesting if if you know the other two
california teams have to move but you're
the first one that pointed this out i
remember the day the schedule came out
you said hey let's look at schedules and
see where stadiums are available for the
three california teams because at that
point in this coveted mess it appeared
that those teams may have to start the
season outside of california and of
course they didn't but now the 49ers
have gone outside these other two two
teams may have to and it looks like it
could be dallas for the rams if they
have to go in la in las vegas for the
chargers if they have to go but you were
on this from from day one saying this
might be a possibility for those three
california teams
well because california had reacted the
most aggressively at that time and that
was the place where we thought it could
happen and arizona jumped off the page
all you had to do was cross-reference
the schedules and there it is san
francisco arizona they can play all
their games there and there's never a
conflict there would be a conflict next
weekend if the chargers had to go to las
vegas for their week 14 game but you
just moved somebody in until the next
day we've seen double headers on mondays
that wouldn't be a big deal easily
accomplished the rams and the cowboys no
conflicts the rest of the season they
would have had something maybe week
three obviously that's not relevant now
and you know what jerry jones is going
to say to the opportunity to throw the
doors open to a t stadium and have 30
000 people show up and they probably
could find 30 000 rams fans in and
around dallas to come to a game and it
would be kind of different it's like an
occasion to get out and do things and
you know this is part of what we're
living in now this duality where there
are people who would would flock to an
opportunity to see the rams play anyone
even if it's not the cowboys
yeah that's what i would be interested
to see mike i was going to say that do
they throw the doors open and put the
fans in the stands which the rams
haven't had at their home games this
season that would be a little different
for the rams to have fans there probably
rooting for them maybe rooting against
them too who knows because obviously a
lot of people aren't going gonna fly in
from los angeles to go uh go to those
games but it would be interesting lion
jerry's pockets maybe a little bit more
help with some of the financial losses
that he and every other owner is gonna
have this season it's not gonna make
much of a dent but it would be
interesting if they open the doors to
the rams games here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports